gráfica la circunferencia x + 2 elevado
al cuadrado más g menos 2 elevado al
cuadrado igual a 4 y en esta aplicación
podemos arrastrar el punto del centro y
también podemos estar moviendo el
perímetro de nuestra circunferencia
entonces de esta forma vamos a tratar de
graficar esta circunferencia que tenemos
expresada con nuestra fórmula verdad
entonces aquí rápidamente lo que tenemos
que ver o más bien lo que tenemos que
recordar es que significa digamos cada
uno de estos números según nuestra
ecuación digamos clásica de la
circunferencia verdad entonces por
ejemplo aquí deberíamos tener x menos la
coordenada x del centro entonces aquí
tenemos más 2 así que eso lo podríamos
expresar como x menos -2 así que menos 2
es nuestra coordenada x del centro de
nuestra circunferencia ahora bien aquí
tenemos ya menos la coordenada en el eje
vertical
nuestro centro verdad entonces aquí
sería menos 2 verdad 2 sería la
coordenada de nuestro centro de la
circunferencia muy bien y finalmente
esto será igual al radio al cuadrado
pero el radio al cuadrado es 4 quiere
decir que el radio eso es así que
podríamos disminuir esto hasta tener un
radio de tamaño 2 verdad y aquí tenemos
la circunferencia verdad y es correcto y
sólo para que quede más claro voy a
dibujar para poder explicar digamos con
detalle todo lo que hice así que vamos a
sacar saquemos el lienzo para dibujar
verdad entonces nosotros teníamos la
ecuación x voy a ponerlo con este color
teníamos la ecuación x + 2 elevado al
cuadrado
y menos 2 esto elevado al cuadrado y
esto era igual a 4 verdad entonces esto
lo podríamos reescribir de la siguiente
forma x menos -2 verdad todo esto
elevado al cuadrado más y menos
2 todo esto también elevado al cuadrado
debe ser igual a 2 2 elevado al cuadrado
verdad y entonces recordemos en esencia
no hay magia no no no hay necesidad de
memorizar la fórmula del de los círculos
y la interpretación verdad lo único que
tenemos que recordar es que esta fórmula
proviene del teorema de pitágoras verdad
con lo que podemos deducir la fórmula de
la distancia entre dos puntos entonces
por ejemplo aquí aquí nos está dando la
digamos la diferencia entre dos puntos o
más bien la el tamaño de el segmento que
conecta dos puntos
en esencia tendremos el el centro de
nuestro círculo que tendrá coordenadas
menos 2,2 y ahora pensamos en un punto
digamos xy aquí tenemos nuestro punto x
coma
y podemos pintar el segmento que 'los
una verdad para poder calcular la
distancia entre esto
dos puntos y además esta fórmula nos
dice que esa distancia tiene que ser dos
verdad entonces aquí por supuesto este
no es el único punto que vista dos de
este punto rosa verdad que es el menos
22 en realidad tenemos todos estos
puntos que distan 2 del de este de aquí
déjenme pintarlo más o menos dejamos un
poco quizás está un poquito feo mi
círculo pero más o menos tenemos la idea
verdad más o menos tenemos la idea de
que todos estos puntos son los que
distan dos de este punto que es el
centro verdad entonces cómo llegamos
esencialmente a esta fórmula que tenemos
acá arriba bueno pues eso lo hacemos con
el teorema de pitágoras verdad porque
entonces aquí podríamos decir que
tenemos x digamos la diferencia que hay
de este x a este menos 2 sería x menos
- 2 verdad todo esto elevado
bueno aquí tendríamos que elevar al
cuadrado más la diferencia que hay de
esta coordenada y a esta coordenada que
es 2 que sería menos 2
y en menos 2 todo esto elevado al
cuadrado nos debe dar la distancia al
cuadrado que es 2 al cuadrado y esto de
hecho podríamos ponerlo más más simple
verdad digamos ya en limpio sería x + 2
al cuadrado más y menos 2 al cuadrado
sería igual a 4 verdad así que cualquier
punto que se encuentre en nuestro
círculo cualquier punto con coordenadas
x que satisface esta ecuación muy bien y
sólo para que quede claro porque en
realidad a mí no me gusta memorizar
fórmulas porque no nos permite
relacionar digamos todo lo que sabemos
con otras cosas verdad así que veamos
realmente cuál es el triángulo que nos
define la distancia entre estos dos
puntos así que vamos a poner aquí por
ejemplo delta x que es nuestro cambio en
x
a hacer con un segmento muy bien aquí
tenemos nuestro cambio en xy el cambio
en x recordemos que es esta coordenada x
menos esta coordenada x que es menos 2
verdad menos 2 y que de hecho lo podemos
poner como x bueno vamos a dejarlo así x
x menos -2 verdad y por otro lado
tenemos nuestro cambio en nuestro cambio
que será esta coordenada que es de menos
esta otra coordenada que es 2 verdad
entonces aquí tenemos nuestro cambio en
x verdad acá tenemos nuestro cambio en g
y esencialmente esto sale del teorema de
pitágoras verdad nuestro cambio en x
será este cateto que hay que elevar al
cuadrado más este cateto al cuadrado que
es el cambio en g y nos debe dar esta
hipotenusa al cuadrado que es 2
al cuadrado verdad y esencialmente es
esto que acabamos de calcular aquí así
que pudimos construir un triángulo
rectángulo y usamos el teorema de
pitágoras para deducir la fórmula del
círculo